schon wieder gibt es Ärger mit wilden
Tieren die Stefanie Hertel und der
Stefan Ross die wollen ein Reh heiraten
retten retten Entschuldigung die haben
sie haben bestimmte verkehrto in
nirgends am Wald im Erzgebirge da
rumpelt ein weißes Reh durch die Gegend
und diese beiden Hübschen wollen heute
nicht dass dieses Reh abgebaut wird und
ich bin jetzt wirklich in der größte Fan
von denen zwar aber da unterstütze ich
Sie total muss ich wirklich sagen sowas
darf nicht passieren wirklich ich käme
jetzt selber nicht so aus in der
Tierwelt und so und deswegen habe ich
einen Vertreter der bayerischen
Staatsregierung eine Stellungnahme
gebeten meine Damen und Herren die
aktuelle Stellungnahme von Herrn Dr
Ulrich kothmann dem Staatssekretär für
Wild Wald und Wiesen sehen Flüsse und
Bäche
ja grüß dich Gott meine Damen und Herren
mein Name ist Dr Ulrich Koopmann ich bin
Staatssekretär für Wildwald und Wiesen
sehen Flüsse und Bäche ja und außerdem
bin ich seit vielen Jahren begeisterter
Jäger und meine Jagdfreunde und ich wir
verstehen uns durchaus als Heger und
Pfleger unserer Flora und Fauna und so
sehr mich persönlich auch das Schicksal
dieses weißen Ries anrührt ich würde es
ja liegen lassen Sie mich das begründen
im MAX einfach nicht diese blöden
Viecher meine jagdfreundin und ich mir
kümmern uns um den Wald schauen damit da
draußen alles schön ist und diese
Viecher ja die Scheren sich doch einen
Dreck um unseren Wald die wollen doch
bloß kostenlos fressen und saufer oder
so schaut es doch aus himi her gut
sakramin nix aber im Ganzen doch blöd im
Wald umeinander und dann alles voll
scheißen der Wald ist doch gerammelt
voll mit Reh Scheiße ja leck mich doch
am Arsch bloß weil dieses blöde Viech
weiß ist wir müssen
[Applaus]